hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play amnesia
obscurity okay so I'm still trying to
figure this out I've got three five and
then two and then I think there were
four rooms in the house but I'm still at
a loss so I need to go out and check one
more time to see the clue was to the
right of the house and I'm not exactly
sure what the hell that means
is it the right outside when you're
facing the outside of the house or
towards the house what is that oh it's
sad slamming down okay so if I'm at this
house and I go right there's a barrel
and it weighted torch and if I go if I
marry here oh wait rocks no and four
rocks there's four rocks murder 13 stars
in the sky five oh whoa well hey well if
I go out and to the right there are five
windows big baby baby baby big Nick Nick
Nick - did I get it - I did r1 stick
some awards on my fence
did I warn okay so three five fought
wave three five five four three five
five three oh come on you stupid bed I'm
gonna kick the [ __ ] out of you whoever
designed this bed that gets caught on
the freakin carpet what the hell in a
handbasket
you gotta bury me maybe there's enough
yeah it's enough god I freaking way I'm
gonna god I'm gonna kill you okay so
three five five four pissed on a brick
does this need to be open three five
five that's had to be it no maybe
five five three oh past three five five
[ __ ] okay there was the one torch one da
bot wait no did I just do five three I
did three five man you know if I saw to
the right of the house and I see two
barrels I'm gonna pick that over a
frickin torch about whatever he done
there hey one of the rods his blood is
on my hands he's dead because of me it
was necessary though I had to do it the
entire village would have been in danger
without the sacrifice the chameleons
purpose is to protect and I must be able
to make the difficult decisions we are
now safe because of me and I made the
right choice his voice I can't get it
out of my head when I left him there on
that table to die he was pleading for
his life begging me to let him go back
to his wife as I left his screams echoed
throughout the tunnels I could hear his
bones snap I didn't know this man very
well aside from seeing him around the
village that made it easier I wonder
what will happen when someone I love
gets picked from the drawing there
aren't that many people in town Brewer
okay so this guy's dad went in vain
cuckoo crazy and obviously he made some
poor life decisions okay whatever
Jesus so I'm guessing he fed some random
stranger to gank again eh
nope nope nope nope Ivan open the [ __ ]
right out of here nope nope I wonder if
there's only one new monster I hope so I
don't want to deal with whatever the
hell they have lined up for me anybody
maybe if I make a mad dash for the exit
I don't know where it would go to leave
hello okay didn't get through this door
haha I have evaded you in my own house
somehow you didn't look very hard for me
okay alright getting out of here going
on my merry way forgetting that ever
happened I don't even know how that
thing got in here did it smash through
the front doors it probably did it
probably did no it came in through the
basement here Elizabeth I want you to
have this necklace
it's for your ceremony in a few days oh
wow no but you can't tell them about it
it's supposed to be a surprise okay
you son of a [ __ ] this guy's father is
horrible
dad that's terrible that's horrible
all right anyway I got the key I can go
into the other houses in the village I
think get the other cycle rods jeez man
come on come on man someone went off way
way way went off the deep end hey what's
going on over there what was that my leg
itches something bad a veneer some bad
having the whole bit was something gonna
bust out of there I know that hello nice
wallpaper okay looking at huh who's
gotta come busting out no really
was that like a ghost of a painting okay
then all right then I guess that was all
there is how I just hurt my neck somehow
Howie okay so that was a lot easier than
I expected it to be was that thought I
heard something
okay all right so far so good
phonograph nothing those photographs
never work hi Alexander what are you
doing here
you're not belong in this custom story
well this place looks downright nice
there's no way I'm getting through why
not I could get through there I see a
chest I want it okay
nice chair spin today while me and my
crew were mining we stumbled across
something quite remarkable it was a
corpse but unlike anything I had ever
seen before
it was looked almost demonic like
creature from hell I wondered if it was
perhaps an undiscovered species living
deep underground or just an anomaly a
mutation of sorts either way I was
curious and brought the body up to the
morgue to be studied William the only
autonomous are not an ottoman in the
area is an old friend of mine and was
glad to help he was astounded it was
unlike anything he'd ever seen
now it claims it will take him a few
days to come up with any useful
conclusions don't look at me like that
I'm trying to make things interesting
different voices and why not and between
my screams of da ho
look I don't think I can handle this
anymore we've gone too far we can't stop
now you're fully aware of the
consequences if we do well yeah I know
but isn't there another way no no this
is the only solution I don't think so I
don't think you've tried everything
don't like this this all is bad news
just like everything else in this game
hello thank you thank you okay this is
that room that I couldn't get in I think
no wait what I thought this was right
this had to be right wait a minute
some done shame raha [ __ ]
I'm the greatest ever ever ever ever
ever ever what's in here
Bing bong got it for phase amplitude rod
oh yeah now I got everything I think we
can go into the mind Hitler it's not
gonna be any more trouble on the way
hopefully not but then again you never
know with these things okay we are on
our way down and I can finally go into
the mind which is totally stupid and
idiotic and insane
really really quite a dumb decision this
is why would I want to do this I do not
know but here I go for Phase Trinity
Blues our goal
oh boy why am I in the mine this is the
last place I would enjoy being at the
moment hello
I'm scared not only phone not only for
my life but the lives of everyone around
me earlier today we excavated what
seemed to be a complex cave system
behind the village beneath the village
we foolishly vented it without
hesitation after our - one of those
things attacked us it was like the
corpse I found the other day except this
one time it was alive killed him killed
them all
I just ran covered in their blood
somehow I managed to escape unarmed what
was it even worth it I can't take this
anymore
I'm scared what if those things find
their way out of the mines and into the
village well then they must be demons
I'm sure of it I must find a way to stop
them thank you thank you carrying on I
like doing different voices for the
notes then again I just like talking so
there's not really much to be amazed at
there okay that looks unstable and seems
to be leaking water excuse me mister
shovel don't need any sass from you I
heard my throat
don't like it down here it's dark just a
little bit further okay yeah it's for
the ceremony you're supposed to dress up
nice it's such an important your brother
doesn't need to count the ceremonies
about you remember Ascot in a hole why
would he do this why wouldn't you just
leave the damn village why people have
an obsession with this village guess I
need to light beacons to make sure I
don't get lost here maybe not maybe
it'll be okay
I see I'm gonna go this way now excuse
me while you [ __ ] off forever
how about that don't tell me that this
is a dead end because I will not like
that it's not locked
for Christ's sake yes that's okay that
thing is now down here with me I am late
boned please don't murder my eyeballs
this is a big circle I don't even know
where I'm going this mine system is huge
please no water monsters please I don't
take kindly to water what is this a save
what Oh interesting the door leading
deeper into the mines is blocked by a
cave-in maybe there's another way
through there is I can see one right
here I need a pipe if I remember from
the original game I need a pipe hey that
didn't hurt me I need to shut off this
waterwheel somehow how about I throw
stuff into it usually works for
everything else ha ha ha
whoa Biscay swig wha yeah that didn't do
anything at all ok that was a dumb idea
I need to find a metal rod while deftly
avoiding the death-defying dangers that
represent in the demonic defilement that
deliberately delegates to death da da da
ba du Clark okay
it's the way I came in this might be the
way I came in
or not or it's not or it's a completely
unique and different way okay what do
you got for me baby and this one cuz I
got so many tinderboxes and this what do
I like having lots of light lots of
light is fun okay that's enough I didn't
even need that it was just a long
hallway why do I constantly waste things
when I need to conserve them actually
tinderboxes are okay I don't need to
waste worry about wasting those data box
those creatures they're intelligent
beings as long as I keep providing them
with sacrifices they stay on the ground
it don't harm me I put together a small
group consisting of me William and a few
other trusted individuals I am the
leader and I've told them if his must be
kept a secret the villagers would never
approve of my actions but I know I'm
doing the right thing I must be I have a
confession however it pains me to admit
this but after so many sacrifice it it
almost becomes oozing the smell of their
blood the sound of ripping flesh maybe
this is just a sign that fate wants me
to continue this is my destiny yep
you're cuckoo crazy alright so I have a
lot of time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos if I've done and as always I will
see you in the next
[Music]